look at that
look at that look at
[Music]
look at that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that actually is accurate
is
[Music]
that
is smarter than you
[Music]
all right listen guys i have to
apologize was something up was the audio
duplicated on that
i have a feeling i'm having an issue
with some settings was was there like a
duplicate audio damn let me see if i can
explore this so here's
here's basically the issue now i just
totally lost my mouse cursor
i just lost my mouse i don't even have a
mouse now
what on earth
i think my battery died on my mouse
all right hold on a second
i'll have to get my uh
corded
mouse man everything going wrong
um okay so let me see like on the mango
one
mangoes my bags are mangoes
[Music]
i love mangoes too
okay
now that we are up under our bodies
regime
so that was monitor output and then
monitor only
let me see if i can
let's just see if i can fix one of these
just to see if i understand what the
issue is
so
monitor and output
and then oh monitor only okay i'm just
gonna quickly go um i'm gonna go back
into that second one
let's see if the issue remains okay i'm
just gonna go into that let's see if i
fixed it
oh wait a second hold on
so i need to take off studio mode okay
let's test it
look at those eyes man that that's that
that dude is gone ladies and gentlemen
alex jones
is now
very very upset with me
look at that okay that's the i figured
out the issue
um
yeah i i need to actually i now
understand what the issue is so i need
monitor only on the individual track
um that's i apologize for that i can
only imagine that that was extremely
unpleasant to look at and to uh listen
to okay
major news as our second hype train of
the month gets going on twitch
the national archives have raided
mar-a-lago
to get back from scrump
documents including remember those love
remember how he fell in love with kim
jong-un and then we fell in love okay
the love letters from kim jong-un which
are what we call presidential records
he took them with them to mar-a-lago
and the national archives after months
of telling trump sir
you can't take that stuff
they've they've gone in and they've
taken it back
uh this is from the washington post as
re-reported by the stamford advocate
president donald trump improperly
removed multiple boxes from the white
house that were retrieved by the
national archives last month from his
mar-a-lago residence because they
contained documents and other items that
should have been turned over to the
agency according to three people
familiar with the visit
um
folks
folks
we were supposed to not vote for hillary
because she couldn't be trusted to do
the right things with documents and
emails
i mean you know
what are we talking about here
the recovery of the boxes from trump's
florida resort
raises new concerns yeah i'll say
about his adherence to the presidential
records act which requires the
preservation of memos letters notes
emails faxes and other written
communications
trump advisors deny any nefarious intent
of course it might only be incompetence
and said the boxes contained mementos
gifts letters from world leaders and
other correspondents
the items included correspondence with
north korean leader kim jong-un guys
imagine for a second what would be
happening on fox right now
if hillary if former president hillary
had letters from putin in her nightstand
okay
just imagine would sean hannity accept
that there was no nefarious intent
would tucker be saying
this is no big deal
they it would be years of hearings they
would be chanting locker oh wait oh no
hold on they already chant that oh
that's that doesn't really change
anything
well anyway you guys understand
what's going on here
um
it is just
unbelievable discussion started last
year
trump's lawyers were explaining to him
you couldn't have that stuff sir you
can't do that
the archives have struggled to cope with
the president who flouted document
retention hey guys remember when people
wrote in and said david the word is
flaunted not flouted and i said guys
it's two different words please with
respect there's the word flaunt
and there's the word flout
and people said no no this is because
you you know they demanded i be banned
and we will ban men saying you've made
up a word because english is your second
language
the word is flouted and here it is the
archives have struggled to cope with the
president who flouted document retention
requirements and frequently ripped up
official documents
leaving hundreds of pages taped back
together do you guys remember when trump
ate
notes
he ate paper notes do you remember that
because it's a real shame
small fuzzy moss remembers it
see if i can find that article
trump ate notes
here it is look look at this these are
allegations of course
look at this
trump 8 sensitive document after cohen
meeting former white house aide claims
former white house aide omarosa
manigault newman has said she walked in
on trump eating paper
after a meeting with michael cohen in
which she believed was an effort to
destroy sensitive information in her new
book unhinged an insider account of the
trump white house newman makes a series
of disturbing and amusing allegations
according to an excerpt of the book
obtained by the washington post newman
recalls quote i saw him put a note in
his mouth since trump was ever the
germaphobe
i was shocked he appeared to be chewing
and swallowing the paper
it must have been something very very
sensitive right he would only swallow
paper with sensitive information on it
um
wow
this is this is completely insane
several unnamed officials said the story
wasn't true
sarah huckabee sanders called newman a
disgruntled former employee
i mean listen we now have confirmation
that he did everything else he ripped
the pieces of paper up into confetti we
got another report over the weekend that
they were sending documents that are
supposed to be part of the presidential
records
to the pentagon in burn bags to be
incinerated
incinerated guys
it is truly something else he's not just
going to eat any paper
he's only going to eat paper with
sensitive information on it
completely out of control completely out
of control so
there it is the uh
trump's mar-a-lago residents
raided
for love letters from kim jong-un
i want to say thanks to deborah wheatley
deborah just did an incredible thing and
signed up on my website joinedpakman.com
also want to thank everybody supporting
us on twitch and that includes man a
whole bunch of people hold on
dark warrior mostly ends very serious
man flea girl
deeper shades of house and then sterling
lana gifted two
that six and six plus one is seven we
will open phone lines at one hundred
absolutely
super chat laura says can't wait to hear
these
i'm not sure i know what laura is
talking about
but i appreciate the support laura
also thanks to mark and cheryl nelson
for signing up on youtube
at the soyboy
level
always appreciated
and i do have one twitch unban request
should i adjudicate this now just to get
it out of the way because i have so much
else going on
uh okay yeah let me get my uh gavel out
the the gavel's unfortunately broken see
it's it's it's just crumbling pieces are
coming off of it regularly
uh
here's a user whose username on twitch
is all numbers
this user came in to a recent stream
and said vaccine has side effects that
last a lifetime that that is untrue
um
why did the public pay for vax research
vaxbot pharma is running his ass
boosters last eight weeks max
is ivermectin a new antiviral they were
banned
and then their unban request is hey i
said a banned word no
you did not say a banned word you
peddled uh incipient
coveted disinformation
and that is a permaban
so there it is very very you're making
it easy for me today guys i have over 1
000 unlistened to voicemails we have
never been over a thousand voicemails in
the history of the show
we will try to make some headway on
those some headway a little bit later
but first i did want to play for you
guys a number of you sent this to me as
some of you may know whoopi goldberg was
recently banned for two months i'm sorry
two weeks from the view for comments
about the holocaust wasn't about race
and it was white people on white people
and all this different stuff
when i want
a reaction to what whoopi said i of
course go to diamond and silk now i
don't know which is diamond and which is
silk but once i've noticed is that the
the young lady on on our right she
doesn't really say anything she's almost
like the hype woman she really she
doesn't say anything
if you pay close attention she kind of
just drops in single words check this
out
i don't advocate for the cancer culture
i'm not for the firing of anyone i'm not
for the suspension of anyone i just want
everyone to have the same even playing
field come on you see what i'm talking
about right so whoopi goldberg was
suspended for two weeks right because
i need a i need a hype woman next to me
when i go guys i have an incredible
story for you today right
uh you are not going to believe the
latest from donald trump mm-hmm i think
it would add a whole new element to the
show she said something about the
holocaust that was inappropriate
and what amazes me is you know they
created this cancer culture that's right
and now this cancer culture is acting
like a beast that's hammering them and
attacking them and now look they have to
you know deal with the consequences
having a boomerang effect that's right
that's what's happening and people are
saying that two weeks suspension is just
like a vacation yeah you see what i'm
saying
because you know uh she need to be on a
toll there's something genius actually
about the whole routine so uh uh just
permanent vacations whatever you think
you need to be on a permanent way i
don't think she i don't but this is what
the public is saying okay okay all right
because to me i think that right now oh
no now okay so now she is contributing
this is a teachable moment for all of us
in society to be able to have but i want
to talk about the fairness what about
the fairness right how is it that the
left can have this teachable moment this
two-week suspension right but i'm
actually thinking if we can isolate some
of the things that she says i can
probably create this on a sound board
and sort of simulate having a hype woman
the right is permanently well let's look
at roseanne barr come on you remember
when they took and they took her they
took her off her show yeah hi rating
show okay because of something that she
tweeted she was never given the
opportunity to have the teachable moment
never she apologized but she was never
given the opportunity that's right they
didn't put her on a suspension they got
rid of her permanently permanently uh
let's talk about megyn kelly when she
mentioned something about blackface and
what happened in their childhood and how
the left demonized her
but then when you look at other people
that's been in blackface jimmy kimmel
uh uh who howard stern are they pro
blackface
other people have been in blackface they
still have their platforms they still
have their shirts so i want to show that
joy banner even joel
that's right so i'm showing the
hypocrisy on the left if you're going to
give one person the opportunity
to go ahead and write their how does
blackface relate to what whoopi said
whoopi is black i don't even understand
what what the why is blackface even at
issue here oh give everyone an
opportunity to write they're wrong
that's right that's right i think it's
time for this cancer culture to just be
done away with we are american band
cancel culture living here in a free
united states okay it's supposed to be
the land of the free and the home of the
by the way are they being interviewed or
is this their show because if this is
the answer to an interview question it's
extremely long brave we should be able
to have open dialogue about anything if
somebody makes a mistake and say
something or even give their opinions
about what you know how they absolutely
feel about it they shouldn't be canceled
if anything we should try to make all
instances a teachable moment well can i
just say this in my humble opinion i
don't think whoopi was given an opinion
she's not making it fashionable
whoa hold on so now she says whoopi was
right that's even weirder the
conversation in law because i don't want
to i don't listen i don't want to beat
nobody when they down right because i
heard that she's threatening to quit
according to the new york post i don't
know how i don't know how true it is
okay anyway i think you guys get it a
very very strange event uh
i don't even know if i should call it an
event per se i want to say thanks to
ricardo perez who just signed up on my
website with the coupon code obama
also thank you to luke pollock who
signed up and also thank you to william
roper who signed up new members eight
nine and ten
let me ask all of you with humility and
with peace and love
start the new year off right and get a
membership on my website i'm going to
call everybody out
as you know we were canceled from
facebook monetization for the vast
majority of january
we are under attack
by the globalists and the globalist
internationalist trotskyite socialists
unlike obama trudeau macron and the rest
of these zio beasts
bish
right oh the bonus show where you want
to make money everybody else that makes
money to find themselves is bad right in
all seriousness i would love it if you
signed up on my website we we do have a
big year ahead and would love to have
your support we are by the way
we are looking very strongly
at um
starting to send
people regularly to do on the ground
interviews at trump events upcoming 2022
midterm debates all sorts of stuff it's
all budget dependent and that's the
price like that's the one thing we want
to add seriously we want to be down on
the ground in the trenches
with the globalish and you know
everybody
um so anyway
memberships you can use the coupon code
obama obama must be spelled
correctly from the standpoint of
incorrect in other words it's an
incorrect spelling but correctly spell
the inquiry does that make sense like
it's obama
and everybody's going to get a thank you
you get a thank you and you get a thank
you everybody gets thanked also thanks
to pro dad build squirrely coney
tool moo badness and half cabbage for
the twitch prime subscriptions all right
let's continue on whoopi she just got
the facts wrong i don't think she was
trying to be racist or had bad
intentions
um
yeah i i don't think i think the
the best interpretation is whoopi was
just wrong
the worst interpretation is without
trying to be racist whoopi was playing
into the same old tropes about jews
aren't really a discriminated against
minority
that sometimes exists
in elements of the left
that's worst case i don't it's somewhere
between the two
it's somewhere between the two
thanks to the old tired road as well we
were going to be speaking today with ian
vash the streamer
bonafide socialist but unfortunately
he is ban hammered ban hammered
from tv
and so uh we couldn't do it
we couldn't do it and i was looking
forward to speaking to him
um
until
i guess he's allowed back on twitch we
can't do it
honestly i got reports from people in my
audience that both
stephen
kenneth destiny
bennell
ii and ian vosh
are
cross-accusing each other of sexual
assault
is that right like they've both claimed
the other has victimized
i guess women i don't it can i'm not
even sure so i wanted to try to talk it
out with everybody
um but i guess it's not gonna happen
today
yeah i i don't really fully understand
the gossip
i don't i don't really know it's it's
all weird but needless to say we're not
talking to anybody about it what was the
name of the website where you type
something and it links the video to when
trump said that that's the fact if you
search for fact base trump
search
um it is the
first thing that comes up
so like for example
i'll show you guys how that works if i
type in like for example
flushing
um
you can then go right to clips about
flushing toilets
and other elements of bathrooms
where
uh
you turn the faucet on in areas where
there's tremendous amounts of water
where the water rushes out to sea
because you could never handle it
and you don't get any water you turn on
the faucet you don't get any water right
they
take a shower and water comes dripping
out it's dripping out very
quietly dripping out very big problem
flushing toilets 10 times 15 times
okay so that's the that's the website
and you can uh
you you can find it there extremely
relevant website historically it's an
historic website okay let's continue do
you guys want to do voicemails next or
do you want to do clips next i've got a
bunch of different things i want to
thank texas bear claw and hydrogen for
the twitch prime subscriptions
also want to say thanks to giancarlo
chiribao
who just signed up with the coupon code
obama obama and his new member number
19. oh new sound board stuff so my
newest stuff is mexellco
and then i do have an alex jones
section now thank your lucky stars every
day you're not dave pacman oh the bonus
show where you want to make money
everybody else that makes money to fund
themselves is bad he's not a knight at
the round table
pac-man never talked to the new world
order pac-man never got tried to get
hired by the kissinger group because
pac-man's a loser he's a sell-out he's
not a real man predator right there
pac-man's a loser
okay so i have that new um
that new thing i think that's all that's
new really
um oh i mean this is sort of new and we
will ban
men and then
other than that
i really do think that's it i've got my
uh
my pasta rant but that's not super new
no spaghetti no ziti no penne no gnocchi
no pepper deli no rotini linguine angel
hair cavatapi tagliatelli fusilli
macaroni farfale conchiglier you
couldn't find lasagna noodles guys
yeah
okay
all right so we got that out of the way
let's get um let's get into some clips
here uh this is a very strange clip now
i i i'm gonna recommend that this one
probably should be like a no kids in the
room sort of clip that i'm about to play
this is someone brilliantly trolling
have you guys heard of the truckers the
truckers that are going completely
bonkers in canada and like they won't
leave they won't stop and it's just all
it's all terrible
um
here's someone who brilliantly trolled
the truckers and this is not safe for
kids just again it's very well done
though
[Music]
justin trudeau puts his semen in the
water supply
don't believe the lies
you judo wants you to drink his [ __ ]
don't do it
do not give in to judo's cup
it is poison
he will kill us
so they're not purebloods we will not
stand for that and that is why we are
here today
justin trudeau fidel castro's son
willfully promotes hatred against any
now is is this actually lance from lance
from the serfs posted this but does
anybody know if this is lance from the
serves doing this trolling
yeah this is basically apartheid
mario
mario what have you done
mario no
no
i trusted you mario
how could you do this to me
flag
uh power right now this is just it's
amazing everybody's so patriotic here in
canada it's it's beautiful
we're being censored live right now
so basically there was a protesters who
like uh don't like these protests
yeah so they brought the bloody roads
and uh on cbc vancouver they not gonna
let you put any comments on it it's
because they're cowards yeah yeah
is it that that is communism right there
that's what the guy said yeah i know
it's like this is this is communism live
i guess it does sound like lance yeah
there's nothing else you know about
about this some [ __ ] [ __ ]
they're censoring us in real time
exactly
[Music]
oh so there's a whole you oh can we find
the entire thing i would want to check
that out youtube.com
i didn't so it is lance that's very
interesting let's see if we can find the
whole thing
um
where is this released on the sixth
that's
wait the serfs i don't even know that
i'm
the serf's tv
there's one video and then there's lance
hasn't uploaded videos for two months
other than the one that's weird is he no
longer doing youtube
i don't even get what's going on
guys it's february 7th
uh this is weird
eleven made me reconsider all all right
let's see let's check this out
this is the trucker can we reconsider
all the preconditions i've ever thought
about freedom
i think we need to be freedom needs to
be crushed forever and the canadian flag
abolished forever
yeah this really has kind of ruined the
canadian flag forever that and you know
the colonial genocide but
mostly the i mean if you notice
everybody who's
waving the flag is white so ah you know
the genocide support is still strong
[Music]
justin trudeau puts his semen in the
water supply
don't believe the lies
judo wants you to drink his [ __ ]
don't do it
do not give in to trudeau's [ __ ]
it is poison
he will kill us
all right so i guess this is what we saw
is there a lot of americans here too
let's skip forward
[Applause]
[Applause]
okay hold on let's see what this is the
founding fathers political spectrum
measured in government coercive power
the real politica spectrum
tyranny
socialism democracy
libertarian republic
freedom zero percent
left right wow what a what a thing huh
what a sign
dear god
[Applause]
[Music]
would you summarize the events of the
day
i would say i no longer have any faith
in humanity and i pray that climate
change wipes us all out pretty soon
[ __ ] this
i'm out
is this supposed to be like fun or what
what's the deal
[Music]
[Music]
it so is all they do lay on the horn
like that's the whole is that the whole
trucker thing i keep hearing about and
also why are there no like actual
[Music]
[Applause]
more wild trucks
[Music]
[Music]
uh-oh is the police coming over
[Music]
what's the meaning of the horse head
like i don't even understand it's i love
it i don't know is it does it have a
particular meaning
tesla very strongly demanding freedom
[Music]
protesters actually arrived at this spot
on tuesday in a show of support for the
demonstrations and coots but it wasn't
until and what do they they want no
vaccines and ivermectin like what is
that the goal what is the goal to stop
vaccination
someone please explain it to me because
it just it's been going on for so long
now
you guys don't know either yeah no i
don't know
they want no mandates
and the mandates
their goal is freedom oh fair that's
fair i didn't think about that
no mandates no masks no vaccines
uh they want to ban men and we will ban
men all right let's let's watch like a
little bit more i would love it if there
were more interviews rather than just
news coverage
let's see if there's any more here
hell yeah
[Applause]
hell yes what can you tell me about this
beautiful piece of art well
we did it
and it's done
[Music]
[Applause]
yes [ __ ] the communists
we'll get them all
hell yeah
white supremacists
oh the black canadian flag
[Music]
do you enjoy the serps but prefer not to
have to use your eyeballs all right so
nice nice job there by lance from the
surfs really getting in there and
getting all the key issues dealt with i
would say i want to say thank you to
multi-beast mystic stitch
crowbars forever
for the twitch prime subscriptions
putting us at 22 i also can't thank
enough people signing up on my website
and that includes heidi christensen who
just signed up using the code obama
patricia hernandez who just signed up
using the code wow 22
as well as terry texter who just signed
up using the code obama obama that puts
us at 25
and i will gladly open phone lines wide
open at 100
if other folks want to sign up thanks to
obama prompt for the 50 super chat hi
david keep up the good work appreciate
that
also matthew says i worked at the oregon
state capitol for a few years the lumber
industry protested by laying on the horn
all day for weeks this is what crazy
right-wingers think is cool wow that's
that's pretty sad uh jermaine with 12
months of membership says david sir i
appreciate all you producer pat and the
staff do for the show thank you
uh also welcome to al
um check your twitter dms lance is there
about the video let me see here
hey i hear you're watching the freedom
rally i can explain what happened if you
want
okay yeah uh let's see maybe
are we if are we connected on uh
discords
let me see here
see if lance is here
god how the hell do i use this
um is it is it lance no is it under
where where is this oh here it is
let's see
okay yeah hey i opened up our last dm on
discord so if lance wants to call in i
would love to hear more about this
that's a good idea
uh
we're friends on discord
so that would be fine i'll keep an eye
on that
uh or on discourse yeah either way i
would i would take either way either way
it's fine
um
let me see i guess i'll text back
uh
discord now let's see if we can get them
on and understand what's going on here
cool all right good very good so so
we'll we'll get back to that um all
right
in the meantime what else did i have for
you guys uh
oh we are sort of monitoring there's
going to be an event in a few minutes i
mean commemorating a tragic milestone
which is 900 000 coveted deaths the
national cathedral i don't know if
biden's going to be there but a couple
other things to look at speaking by the
way speaking of the horn honking
anti-vaxx person arrested by ottawa
police for honking horn non-stop other
anti-vaxxers film and harass police i
want to take a look at this
hey
you're back
we're back we're filming we're doing our
part
it's all on video no don't say anything
don't say anything you know what to do
you're a [ __ ] goof hey rich rich
stand down
stand down stand down
no it's peaceful
what's with all the swearing with these
people huh
[ __ ] touch me
this is going right to the media
youtube what's your name
what's your name yes and we will all be
the reaction will be wow
you anti-vaxxers are really annoying
what's your name and badge number
what's your name and badge number one
yeah you're a son look they're hurting
an old man
a canadian citizen
it's communism
so they have the communism stuff there
too huh
i mean people alleging it is what i mean
communist you stand with the communist
[ __ ] government
call your police chief you'll back you
up
call the police call your police
an old man shame on you
shame on you
what a mess shame on you this guy is
tiny by the way huh is that an old man
is it actually an old man
yeah i know he beat the horn
what the [ __ ] do they represent they
represent trudeau
and and the police
chief
slowly that's what they represent hate
division
you are not protecting and serving
nobody
communism right here lest we forget
fight for your
this seems almost as weaponized as what
we have in the united states guys i know
that we often just like kind of assume
that it's only this insane here
it actually seems like in parts of
canada i know alberta has a lot of
cuckoo stuff going on and it seems
recently in ottawa because of this
trucker thing
this is all this is just as bad as what
we have here i mean i guess there's not
as much of it they have fewer people and
and that type of thing but
that's
pretty bad
it sounds like what we have here right
this is [ __ ] communist [ __ ]
police
old man
what's your name and badge number sir
what's your name and badge number sir
you have nothing to do with this what's
your yes i do i'm not canadian
what is your name
[Music]
you do that to the canadian citizens of
canada what did we do everything about
this is communist in stalinist russia
the police even had all this great
equipment and vehicles like this this
this is just ripe from stalinist russia
man what a disaster
what a disastrous situation
um
hold on let me see sure one sec what's
your discord
uh i'll dmu
so i think we're going to talk to lance
from the surfs here
about the video that he did
at the uh at the protests
um
let's see
okay we're linking up with him that's a
good idea guys that was i i like that
idea
and we'll see what the story is i mean
quite an insane situation
all right okay i think we're going to
connect with lance here
yeah it's an impromptu interview very
impromptu oh thank you to joseph
koladenko for signing up on my website
with the coupon code obama obama also
thanks to new trin for signing up on my
website with that very same code
numbers 26 and 27 today also thanks to
windup cat for the twitch prime
subscription your number 28
which i appreciate
they don't want mandates to go to the
u.s okay so that's why that's why
they're protesting
uh
let's see here
um
see if lance is ready
dm'd you i did just now
okay so we're gonna wait and see we're
gonna talk to lance yeah my favorite
moment
is definitely
i think this is the funniest moment
justin trudeau puts his senior in the
water supply
don't believe the lies
judo wants you to drink his cub
don't do it
man that it is tough to find a funnier
moment than that
from the uh
from the entire thing oh thanks also to
heather gannon heather just signed up at
joinedpakman.com number 29 today thank
you heather you're a true hero
a true hero
hard to oh hold on here's lance let me
see here join call
hey lance
can you hear me hey yes hold on let me
see if i can pull you in here oh i don't
know if i'm set up to get your video on
um
yeah i i was not set up for a discord
discord video so we'll be able to hear
you but my audience won't be able to see
you
that that's okay i can i can answer
questions via the voice so okay so is it
true that trudeau is putting his semen
in the water is that true
i gotta be honest uh david the one of
the first times you pulled me on the
show i didn't know that would be the
opening question i wasn't i wasn't ready
for this one i don't have my cards uh
no to the best of my knowledge it's not
happening right now so okay so so first
of all this video that you made is this
a compilation from several days
yeah so the second half was me a couple
weeks ago at an anti-vaxx rally uh that
took place in the city and then the
first half of it is uh the trucker
protest rally that just happened
okay so
do the truckers they're they're opposed
to
mandates for going back and forth over
the
border that's their main grievance
yeah so just to be clear only about 10
of truckers in canada are unvaccinated
and that um that imposition goes both
ways i mean there's only so much that if
they got their demands of having all
restrictions lifted they would still
have to contend with the us canada
border of which they still require uh to
be vaccinated uh to go over there uh and
also there's an organization called the
canadian trucker alliance for the cta
they were anti-vaccine mandates but
they've come out emphatically saying
they do not support this convoy or what
has taken place okay so 90 of the
truckers are vaccinated of the 10 that
aren't
some of them want to end the mandates
those have been the at the crux of the
protests
yeah um i don't know how much you've
shown your audience but one of the
original key organizers is a guy who
goes by the name of pat king um he is
someone they're trying to distance
themselves from right now because
unfortunately he's there a lot of video
surfaces of him talking about how
there's a great replacement taking place
how the superiority of the anglo-saxon
bloodline has to be preserved and all
that that's where a lot of the like this
could have credible ties to the far
right started coming from yeah also for
the gofundme itself that was organized
one of the two gofundme organizers
tamara lich she is a well-known figure
in canada for being a part of the
separatist party or the exit party that
is actually trying to get alberta to
seed from canada and join the the
greater united states
got it okay and so
there's been anecdotal reporting about
swastikas there
great replacement white supremacist
stuff don't tread on me
yellow jewish stars all this different
stuff and the the people who love the
rally are saying
that's like
0.0001 percent those people aren't even
welcome there it's unfair to focus on
that what do you think about the role of
that stuff in this whole thing
so i i think it is it would be
disingenuous to say that this is an
overwhelmingly simply a far-right rally
or something like that what i would say
is that you do have to look at how some
of the key organizers and some of the
members who are the people collecting
money or trying to organize events do
have very strong and well documented
ties to the far right that's been widely
reported on at this point i would
recommend people check out antihate.ca
which does a really good job of covering
the far right in canada we have a a
griper movement in this country groipers
if you don't know are nick fuentes uh
kind of uh american nationalists in
canada that's called canada first and
they're also very closely tied with this
the thing that some people should ask
themselves is if people who fly
swastikas and confederate flags and
don't step on snack and keck flags are
all comfortable and feel safe in amongst
your rally then it might be saying
something right i don't think that they
overwhelmingly represent the vast
majority of people who are attending
these it's it's a very uh varied mix
right but at that same rally that i
attended in vancouver we did hear a
speech about how the globalist elites uh
are trying to control us that there is a
ruling class of bankers you know things
very very uh masked off dog whistles are
still kind of
woven in there so it's like anything
else it's grown to a size where if you
have two or three thousand people or
even at this point five thousand people
were there on wednesday or sorry on
saturday apparently yes a lot of people
are just showing up because they are fed
up with mandates a lot of people are
showing up because they're fed up with
uh restrictions whatever that is and
they aren't necessarily far right
nationalists but they are also people
who are involved in those organizations
who are there as well now
this is a question from my audience the
people that the only thing they have is
a canadian flag
are
are those most what's are they on a
particular side the people who just have
a canadian flag
i mean
like without having any scientific
polling data in front of me i can't
really say i would say the vast majority
of them are people who just want an end
to the restrictions okay uh
yeah and
like it's one of those things i try to
explain to people it doesn't matter if
you're on the left or the right i don't
think anyone is having a great time
right like no no one is enjoying this no
one likes wearing masks no one likes
social distancing no one likes not being
able to hug their grandmothers or their
parents just a lot of people have kind
of recognized that there is a set amount
of things that if you do them you will
in turn get better results like i think
by ratio of our population if we had the
same levels of covet death as america we
would have almost doubled the amount of
people who died in this country from
covet 19. so there is something to be
said about a lot of these uh measures
that were put in place that have
actually saved countless lives in terms
of the the law there
uh i i just haven't been follow i know
about the law to go to canada and then
to come back to the united states from
canada but in terms of inside of canada
is there federal law on who must be
vaccinated and then is there provincial
law as well that varies
so all the restrictions that they're
trying to get the federal government to
i guess take down are actually measures
that are put on by provincial health
authorities each province in canada has
their own provincial health authority
and each provincial health authority has
kind of dictated how each province
should uh govern themselves and in that
respect that's why some provinces did a
lot better than other provinces based on
what kind of measures or implementations
they put in so you might see i don't
know if you've watched the viral clip of
a guy screaming at the truckers saying
there's nothing the federal government
can do in this place now uh in terms of
federal employee requirements that is
true they could lift uh any requirements
that are necessary for federal employees
so they can write that one biggest
problem i find though is that even if
they were to lift uh the vaccine uh
restriction for truckers coming into the
country that will not stop uh the u.s uh
uh enforcement on the other end right
it's like their demands right now is
what i would kind of characterize as
unreasonable because they are one of two
things the official demands are a
all restrictions are lifted including
masks vaccine restrictions social
distancing everything or the government
the democratically elected government
effectively retires it's one of those
two
what is an example of a province that's
really strict versus one that's less
strict
uh the less strict i would put into
alberta for a category and for an
example of what happened there over the
summer um jason kenney the premier of
alberta decided that he wanted to turn
alberta into a tourist destination so
oh my apologies what is that
that was a that was a twitch sound okay
i all of a sudden wondered if that was
on my hand
my yeah my apologies but anyways um
uh yeah so jason kenny the premier of
alberta decided he wanted to turn
alberta into a tourist destination over
the summer and so he did this huge
campaign ad where it was basically like
we're lifting all restrictions come to
alberta we're not like the other
provinces you know you can come and
enjoy the party enjoy the stampede enjoy
all this and then their numbers got
completely out of control right as a
direct result um somewhere like canada
uh sorry somewhere like british columbia
had uh i guess what you could consider
stronger restrictions and that uh we
have a limit on how many people you can
gather with in a restaurant it's a limit
of six people uh sports events at
certain times may be reduced to half the
capacity uh there is vaccine
requirements for all restaurants movie
theaters uh public areas like that so
that might be considered um to be a
little bit more restrictive uh and uh
it's like anything else it's a varying
degrees of success so it's not sounding
it's not sounding like oppressive
communism i guess
well the thing is is like
we don't have a lockdown in this country
we haven't like like i can't think of a
province that is locked down there there
is no lockdown so people who are
directly out there saying end the
lockdowns i i was like you won you got
exactly what you're asking for yeah
there's no lockdowns in this country i
mean there is what they consider to be
like they're calling it apartheid
because they say that there's two tiers
of citizens now the the vax and the
unvaccinated which i mean there's always
sometimes a fun thing trying to explain
to them what actual apartheid is
compared to you choosing not to want to
be vaccinated for your own purposes but
but in terms of so so
uh in terms of um you know there have
been these ideas floated of like if
you're unvaccinated by choice you might
be triaged differently at hospitals that
were like kind of bad considered in the
united states is that conversation
happening in canada
uh the the closest we've come to that is
i believe quebec initially stated that
they were going to start fining uh
people who were unvaccinated uh as a
measure to try and i guess put that
money back into the public health care
system because i mean the argument would
be that they are becoming an undue
burden on the public health care system
as the vast majority of people now who
are being hospitalized for cover 19 are
unvaccinated but um i i i simply don't
really ever want to give that kind of an
argument merit because to me i don't see
where it ends like if someone is a
smoker do they not should they not have
access to public health care if someone
is it gets very complicated
yeah exactly yeah no we've had that
conversation as well and you know for
something like organ transplants at
least in the us it's common that
there are all sorts of different
uh standards applied into who is likely
to get the most use out of a donated
organ and so
now
covet vaccination status is one of many
things that's being considered but
when we're to your point it starts to
become more about
do smokers get any treatment or if you
eat more than a certain amount of uh
you know red meat it starts to get very
complex
although that that does exist in canada
as well there is there is a triage
system for organ donation so i believe
if you were an alcoholic or if you were
smoker you probably won't be on the list
for getting a donated organ for uh your
liver or your your lungs in that case
but um yeah no there hasn't been a
demonstratable example of people being
refused uh you know
public healthcare because they were
unvaccinated gotcha gotcha well the
video is both horrifying informative and
hilarious and so i think that in our in
our space that's a pretty good trio you
know it's what i think a lot of people
are going for
well i appreciate it and i'm happy to
report that uh we we didn't uh didn't
get covered so far from oh that's good
yes have you had it at all
uh i don't know i'm like everyone else i
i like i i've gone through maybe like
six or seven times where i thought i've
had it and then i've done uh rapid tests
and then it comes back negative and then
a friend of mine has a positive contact
and i think yeah but officially no
yeah i've had phantom coveted symptoms
for two years i've had the longest
phantom case of covid maybe on on the
planet but i've never actually had a
positive test
that's good right yeah i mean i think so
i think so i'd take phantom covet over
real cove at any any day uh all right
lance thanks for getting on with us so
quickly we really enjoyed the video
oh no thanks for watching it thanks for
showing everybody i appreciate that too
have a good one all right we'll talk to
you soon take care bye
uh all right there is lance
lance explaining his video to us and he
was here thanks to you guys you all
suggested it and we made it
we made it happen let me say thanks to a
few other twitch supporters including
let me make sure i get these names right
um
mcleiger
dw
rec
anir bhanbagi
nolan
andy yamashiro nigel dugan and jen here
putting us at
that's
34. over on the website i want to say
thanks to julian penfold who just signed
up with the coupon code obama obama
maria christensen who just signed up
with the code obama
[Music]
who used that very same coupon code
putting us at 37
for the day
um
all right
colin sir i'm surprised you didn't
include your homeland of belgium when
considering immigration destinations
yeah i know i did does anybody if
anybody can link me to where i
supposedly said i'm from belgium i would
love it because a couple people now have
written in saying they thought i was
from belgium i've been to belgium once
loved it
absolutely loved it but i would love to
figure out the oranges of that
um
john oliver said nazis are like stray
cats if they're hanging around it's
because you're feeding them anti-mandate
protesters won't be able to shake the
far right showing up at their rallies of
course with without a doubt without
there's no question about that they will
be dealing with it for a very long time
all right so we got that let's go to
some other things here what else do i
have
oh here i'm trying to figure this out
marjorie taylor green
showed up on the floor of the house
today to complain about masks
and she's
very out of breath
i i don't know why i mean let's just
listen to it what she says is wacky but
her being out of breath is also very
strange georgia seek recognition
mr speaker i'd like to address the house
about how children feel about masks
for one minute the gentle lady is seeing
seeking unanimous concern
for one minute without objection
gentlelady is recognized
thank you mr speaker i'd like to talk
about how children feel about mask
you see the deep breath it reminds me of
the day trump left the hospital with
covet
super bowl games where adults are filled
filling stadiums without masks and
enjoying themselves while they see
concerts happen they see people go to
work they see adults going many places
all over this country without masks they
are forced to wear masks every single
day at school and it's wrong actually
it's child abuse now i know that sounds
like strong words but it really is
because children why does she say people
are forced to wear mask singular
isn't that a strange thing
children everywhere are wearing masks
not at risk of covid19 as a matter of
fact children are at the lowest risk but
do you know what's harmful to children
isn't that like a two-year-old talking
point
having their faces covered all day long
at school not being able to see each
other's faces not being able to see
their teachers faces not being able to
learn properly speech emotions and
having that connection seeing each
other's faces and learning from adults
seeing each other's faces now while
democrats are going on with the mask for
thee and not for me kids have had enough
and they're going to be future voters
and they are sick and tired of being and
she's still out of breath to wear a mask
it needs to end masking children is
child abuse
pursuant to call
okay
so i mean okay there's marjorie taylor
green um here is lara trump at
mar-a-lago taki telling guests over the
weekend to take a shot of bourbon before
donating to eric's
cancer charity hmm
this is me ladies and gentlemen how's
everybody's evening going tonight at
quick
mar-a-lago
real quick and i know paige wants to
keep things quick because we don't want
to be up here all night y'all have some
bourbon in front of you i'm going to
suggest before we start raising money
everybody take a shot of bourbon
okay wet your whistle a little get loose
get comfortable
get ready to enjoy yourself
at this point it's like is any trump
charity it is every trump trump charity
a scam
yeah cheers okay
so recommending shots at mar-a-lago um
here's rand paul
saying uh what the truckers in canada
are doing is great you know someone's
got to get up there and honk horns you
release that and somebody's got to stand
up whether it's putting your semi in the
middle of a town and honking the horn or
whatever or whether it's parents going
to a school board meeting
these people
never let go of our freedoms or our
children if we do not push back is there
anyone more simultaneously banal but
also
uh
horrifyingly
gross
and repulsive as rand paul like he's
simultaneously banal and pedantic and
also disgusting it's a very very it's
like a weird combination
john says in quebec movie theaters and
shows open today at 50 capacity
restaurants last week gyms next week all
50 capacity
very good
she must have took english from trump
university
bradley our future voters are learning
to donate while drunk sir yes exactly
exactly big thank you to aliens exist
who signed up on my website with the
coupon code obama obama and his new
member number 38. also thanks to
dustan
oh wait i already thanked dustin for the
twitch prime subscription thank you very
much appreciate that okay uh we dealt
with that we dealt with this
um
okay this is happening now i guess let's
see
these are bells commemorating
thousand dead of covid
[Music]
okay
i think we sort of get the um i think we
sort of get the picture okay
do you guys want to play
one or two rounds of deepak chopra
versus jordan peterson i have the game
ready my colleague john has presented me
with the game
i don't want to play every round because
um
i want to you know spread it out because
we've got a lot of different streams
coming up is that a game people would be
interested in playing right now this
this could be the greatest game show
since
who wants to be a millionaire
people like it okay
all right let's do it here is the game
let's go to it
hold on is this it
let me see here
okay
oh man
i need to get the right
hmm
all right let me fix this
we are going to get this i want to make
sure the entire thing is on the screen
here
let's see so we're going to go like this
here
okay i do need my moderators to help me
here because we need to do
we need to do for each question
i want to do polls on twitch
and on facebook okay so moderators
please set up polls on twitch and i'm
sorry twitch and youtube right now
twitch in youtube right now and it
should be
question one
peterson or chopra all right here's the
gist
i believe jordan peterson has become
essentially a deepak chopra-like figure
i believe they both
use similar word salads
and that the things they say are
indistinguishable
okay so let's go to the first one please
set up the poll
now my friends here's the first quote we
are to decide is this a chopra quote or
is it a jordan peterson quote science
has become so arrogant in its premise
that it has all the answers hold on i
need like game show music i need that on
my sound board let me see here
game show
music um
it's almost like uh
price is right would almost be like the
right thing
i think that's what we should really
kind of have here
[Music]
okay
science has become so arrogant in its
premise that it has all the answers
we have a uh poll happening
on twitch right now
and we have no poll happening on youtube
okay let me do a poll so this is
question one
jordan peterson
deepak chopra
let's see what people think and you can
now vote on youtube as well
okay so far over on twitch
peterson is leading peterson is leading
over on
youtube peterson also leading
wow
[Music]
okay
let's take a look
science has become so arrogant in its
premise that it has all the answers it
sounds like something peterson would say
but i think the whole point of the game
here
is it's difficult to tell i'm gonna go
with
this is
i believe this is deepak chopra all
right i'm gonna click on the answer
let's take
look there are fundamentalists in
happens
a
science that is absolutely wrong
science's quest is to try to sort out to
tease out those bits that we don't have
science has become so arrogant in its um
in its premise that it has all the
answers in a mechanistic approach
that it has whilst it has gotten rid of
lots of things like polio and malaria
and tuberculosis in many parts of the
world
we are now seeing the emergence of
modern epidemics that are a result of
some of the things that have come about
suicide there it is folks it was deepak
chopra okay so that's how the game works
you guys does everybody understand how
the game works
nobody knows how the game works okay all
right
let's go to the second one we're gonna
do one more and then we're gonna save
these we're gonna save these okay
because i wanna make sure that that we
keep these all right let's go back to
question two
why are the unvaccinated all of the
sudden a danger
i certainly don't understand the push to
get children vaccinated i think that's
absolutely reprehensible okay
let's get one new one going on twitch
please new one going on twitch and i'm
gonna get a new poll
going on youtube this is question two
question two
jordan peterson
deepak chopra let's see what the
community says
[Music]
do we have a new one going on twitch we
don't
okay
93
say this was jordan peterson 93 you can
vote right now on youtube
i guess there's a new poll going on
twitch there is okay
peterson crushing crushing crushing
wow
[Music]
okay
all right let's check it out i also
believe that this is jordan peterson i
do believe that this is jordan peterson
let's take a look together
and see if we can figure it out i am
clicking on answer
oh no oh my god hold on everything's
going wrong
oh god
hold on here it is
oh boy let me let me click it in a
different way
oh man something is going wrong here
with my button
nope that's not it hold on a second
oh god everything's happening we're
gonna get to it in a second
oh man
uh let me see how i can do this
it's kind of like off the screen stand
by everybody we are experiencing
technical difficulties here it is
okay
and it is
why are they vaccinated all of a sudden
the unvaccinated all of a sudden jordan
peterson
and i certainly don't understand the
push to get children vaccinated i think
that's i think that's
i think that's absolutely reprehensible
there it is
there it is it is indeed jordan peterson
if you guessed jordan peterson
you are right so congratulations to
everybody
who is two of two
actually maybe we should be using this
right
okay good so
we have more to come
more to come because we have others with
the game
and we will um we we will play again for
sure we will absolutely play again i
hope people like that game deepak chopra
vs jordan peterson
uh okay
i want to say a big thank you
to debbie hunt for signing up with the
coupon code obama
your new member number 39
over on twitch thank you to copper bunny
amber
ambereshki was here the hobo ms frazzled
putting us at 43
and i very much
appreciate that okay let's just do a
couple other little things that i have
for you producer pat suggested to me
that i play one game of six degrees of
wikipedia
here's the way that this game works okay
we're gonna try to find the shortest
path between two wiki articles today
let's do
between the wiki page for the david
pakman show
two
satsuma
oranges
citrus okay so we're gonna see if we can
connect
the david pakman show to citrus unshu
which is the name for
sumo citrus satsuma oranges let's see if
we can do it okay
found three oh wait a sec hold on a
second this is oh this isn't the game
this just gives you the answer
i'm an idiot
let's see let's see what it is
so you can go oh wow it two of the three
paths between my show and citrus go
through jews
so david pakman's show
youtube afrikaans citrus on shoe
david pakman show jews afrikaans citrus
david pakistan jews yellow citron and
then citrus unshoe
man okay so this is actually not the way
to do it
um
i guess we won guys
all right
i'm gonna have to reset on this game
clearly i'm not prepared to play it
correctly
uh
i i did not realize that it that this
website just gave me the answers
that's weird
all right so let's do let's just we'll
do a geoguessr instead yeah that's fine
that's fine all right let's do a classic
geo guesser we will go world people seem
to love this we've got five minutes on
the clock go go let's start okay we have
snow where in the world could we be we
have snow
and we have some overlap
uh
this is very very tough we're like on
top of a mountain here
this one seems exceedingly difficult
this could be anywhere
this could be argentina
let's see if we can get all the way down
to the bottom of the mountain i mean
this is crazy
this isn't even this isn't even possible
right
i mean i can't even get down the
mountain
i can only go up it
this is the most difficult one i've ever
seen
let's see if we can take this road
around
hmm
we may need more than five minutes on
this one
wow i can't see anything
it's like a mountain we can't get down
all right this is getting us down the
mountain
this could truly be almost anywhere
okay it's not cancun i got that but
i'm just trying to get down the hill
this is bonkers i'm just clicking as
much as i can
there's just nothing here
all right we're sort of getting death
this is crazy
i mean at a certain point we'll just
have to get i'm not going to abandon it
but we might just have to guess
i would love to be able to click all the
way at the bottom of the hill
just doesn't work
and it doesn't let me go down any
further that's what's crazy
all right let's um
what are what are we thinking are we
thinking northern hemisphere
let's see i mean i just have no frame of
reference
no frame of reference at all
yeah i'm just gonna go with up here but
but it's like that doesn't even really
feel right to me
you know what i'm going to go with i'm
just going to go random
i'm going to go with this is somewhere
in the swiss alps
i'm going to go with uh
i'm just gonna go right here i mean who
who the hell knows
okay it was in japan
it was in japan all right let's try
another one and see if we have better
luck that's exceedingly difficult
alright here we go here's a new one
let's start seeing if we can identify
some elements here
hmm
this is very american feeling
could be u.s could be canada but i'd
like to see a stop sign
first um
there there's definitely an american
feel to this
see if we get to a road sign
uh
is that potentially a blurred out new
hampshire plate
american muscle car
completely impractical truck
yeah i mean this this feels like it
could be the united states
still thinking probably u.s
okay hold on we got to look at this sign
school bus stop ahead
that's
certainly an american sign canada might
have the exact same sign
but it's definitely northern hemisphere
let's take a look at this
okay that's uh
what state is that is that is that
virginia
north carolina okay i can't even
recognize the so i think we're
kentucky it's kentucky exactly
all right so we're in kentucky
let's see if we can find
something more specific
it's gonna be probably pretty tough
it's like someone left some trash out
let's see if we can zoom to the end of
this road extremely rural here
let's see what we have here
mason
pointer oh let's see what this is
can't really glean anything from that
okay
do we just stay on the same road
i think we do
thinking northern kentucky
let's see if we can
yeah okay i mean the other cars aren't
really telling us
anything this isn't hilly enough to be
northern kentucky that's interesting
i mean listen i unless i drive miles
down the road here i just don't think
for someone with my familiarity
we're gonna get any information that's
actionable
for me
all right well let's see
let's get into kentucky here
i'm thinking maybe more in this area
here this eastern part of the state is
that possible
oh you're thinking
western
towards the west
it's flatter to the west that's a good
point
let's go uh i'm just gonna go here let's
see where we're at oh look at that
18 kilometers away
it was in uh i guess near penrod
kentucky
pretty solid
pretty solid i must say pretty pretty
solid guess
all right everybody that's everything i
have for today thank you for joining me
more streams upcoming
everybody take care
uh make sure to have your pets spayed or
neutered
and all of that stuff all right we'll be
back with everybody very soon that was
geo guesser if you want to keep playing
on your own thank you